LRVM is a classic systems research work.
You understand what is the pain point for
system developers. Once you understand the pain
point, then it becomes easy to think about
what solution you can bring to the
table to solve it pain point. Managing persistence
for critical data structures is the pain
point that is identified by the LRVM work.
LRVM proposes using lightweight transactions, that is, a transaction without
all the heavyweight asset properties
usually associated with transactions in database
literature. And this lightweight transaction is going to give the needed
persistent semantics for designing robust subsystems that can tolerate crashes.